and i will let mr ali lick the hummus
off my feet
and
mr ali is paying me 50 000 u.s dollars
for this
today's topic uh someone sent me this
clip from logan paul's podcast i thought
it was interesting
just to be clear so uh these two
individuals here on on screen they were
in uh uh ibiza ibiza ibiza is banging
ibiza is it a beer ibiza
all right is that how they say though
ibiza spanish people
ibiza but anyways they were there uh i
guess they were partying and uh
so we're at this place called cipriani
and there are women everywhere many of
them with one man at the table
one man five women one man eight women
strange
there's so many women at these days odd
right so we have our dinner and we're
hanging out and the vibe is going way up
on this night it's our first night in
ibiza and we start looking around we're
like wow that's impressive wow that's
impressive which table are we going to
go to to talk to to try to get girls to
come back and like all party and people
that come back to part at the hotel you
know what the answer is george every
single [ __ ] one of them
every single girl in that restaurant
left the table that they were at to come
back to our double penthouse hotel in
ibiza
yeah we're all just partying hanging out
listening to music everybody's enjoying
their spirits having a good time
and we asked that person hey man
what's the deal with these girls like
they're like what's their deal like
they're from all different countries
like how did they get here who are they
with
and he was like they're all mahi mahi
what they're all mine mahi-mahi
a code word that he had been throwing
around for working women
so i asked the question i said yo which
like just by the way once again like you
said out of just curiosity and halfway
joking
which one of these girls is here like
working
and his answer
all of them oh my god every single girl
i said brother that's not possible
there's no way there's no way these are
stunning
women i said those two over there
it's not possible me and logan been
looking saying these girls are
absolutely stunning
he walks over
has a conversation comes back five
minutes later
1500.
but we were stunned at how true his
statement was and we later found out
even like some people who are like
very well known
have a price very well known
what's so interesting about that
i mean at a place where there's drugs
money
women
people have prices
no he was talking about ladies with huge
instagram followings yeah he didn't know
but i thought it was interesting
considering he's somebody with a giant
following who's in the social media
sphere i'm like you didn't know that a
lot of these
instagram girls going to dubai
right taking all these trips
you didn't know you didn't know
and a lot of people are not aware of
this right but when you see these
millions of followers most of them a lot
of them are bought a lot of the times
but a lot of these girls
behind closed doors which is hey listen
i got no problem with it you want a
trick trick
but they selling
if you guys didn't know they sound
i've known about this since about
2015-ish because there's a website
terrible website it was called tag the
sponsor i used to expose instagram girls
who would be willing to go to dubai to
do do do contracts if you don't know
what a doodoo contract is dudu right
poop contract right they get poo'd peed
on turning into porta potties all right
for like 20k and a weekend some of these
girls will do anything
right so while you're over there beating
your meat to these girls pictures while
they ain't a thong or someone else who's
[ __ ] on them facts
he didn't know
so he goes and he sees these tens out of
tens he's like what
listen when someone's offering you a
hundred thousand dollars for two weeks
in dubai you gotta service a bunch of
people you're probably gonna go
why are you looking at me like that
why are you looking at me like that abba
cause i worked in a hotel with princess
from dubai
it's there for a reason yo there's a
reason why you work in those hotels and
they make you sign an nda
there's a reason
let me just keep going very well you
guys want to hear the story that i heard
i i'm not going to mention names
obviously out of respect but there was a
it was a good friend of mine which you
guys know i mentioned after the podcast
he had a girlfriend
and she like got guilty and like exposed
herself and her friends and they're
really big
george yeah so i think the reason why
she's confessed
and mind you none of this is proven by
me i haven't seen i ever heard but like
bro
he came to my house crying telling me
this [ __ ] dude like so like that [ __ ] it
hit hard but basically what i heard
one of her friends i'll just get to that
part uh
she went to a certain area in the world
and did some things for cash
yeah that she's probably not proud of
nor would her parents be proud of
and i don't know if she was
absent-minded or maybe she didn't really
know about the border transaction you
can't bring cash
oh yeah 10k so she had
150 000.
and then she has a hundred and fifty
grand for a week's work and then she has
to explain why she has 150 grain to the
border
so i don't even know the rest of the
video
but i know my bedroom i know my border
patrol so she went to that part of the
country
got paid 150 grand cash
for modeling
she was stupid amount of money
brought all that cash back
got cut because you know the x-ray your
luggage is
she got cut
with that
what happened
they seized the money
because she couldn't prove where it was
from
not a bit not part they seized the money
somebody gave her that much money
they seized the money and she can get a
case for that
because she can't prove it
where it's from the reason why i bring
this up it's a lot of times people
idolize these people who have huge
followings not recognizing some of the
stuff they have to do to get those
followings whether it's buying followers
or doing stuff and some of the stuff
they have to do to maintain that money i
can assure you those crazy trips that
you see them on the private jets that
everyone's seemingly flying on they
don't pay for themselves you paying
right paying with your money paying with
your sweat or paying with some doodle on
you but you're paying
and it's not the same people that's not
saying it's not shaming just realizing
what they're doing people are
misrepresenting the reality of the lives
they lived and they're not showing you
what they have to do behind closed doors
in order to get that lifestyle in order
to get that lifestyle that's why i be
laughing when i see a bunch of girls
posting on dubai i'm like i know you
broke
what you doing out there writing these
camels why is this prince looking [ __ ]
riding with you
i know you're broke i know you
but it's cool i ain't mad at you get
your money but don't talk about like man
it feels so good to work hard and get
far
okay cool story
cool story
some of them get asked to do illegal
stuff of course
yes of course everything from
animals to underage people
yeah it goes far do you want to see a
crazy video
sure
okay
so there's people who run this website
they hit up these instagram models they
make the offers and they tell them what
they want sometimes they send in videos
this is a model instagram model okay
who sent in the video of what she was
going to do and she read it out
hi
my name is aliana luciada gosales and
i'm 20 years old 26 years old i'm
willing to come to dubai to susan ali
in dubai we have a cd check and mr ali
too
after that we are having unprotected sex
and i will let mr ali lick the woman off
my feet i will also
[ __ ]
his virgin brother
who is 13 years old
and i will let him lick my
and
[ __ ] me anna
mr ali is paying me 50 000 us
dollars
for
this
and i will receive 25 000 us dollars
two weeks before i come to dubai
this is my passport
and thank you so much mr ali for the
invitation and i can't wait to finally
meet you
that's basic [ __ ]
yeah i mean yeah
begging kids
and this is like some of the lighter
stuff there's something that involves
camels there's something that like you
know 13 of us are rolled through we
pooping in your mouth
weird stuff okay i'm telling you it gets
crazy
and you're talking about some of the
most attractive women in the world
for money
so and all people like oh they're
getting taken advantage of chill out
okay
chill out sorry but uh jumping in for a
hundred thousand dollar bags that's easy
money
they're choosing easy money the problem
is not what they're doing or whatever
they're doing that the sex for the money
thing we're over that
we don't care yeah
we don't we don't care i don't care we
really don't care it's not you have to
just know what you're doing all that
person is living in life and this that
when they tell you it's hard work it's
hard work okay and you have to
know what they're willing to give away
to have that
and after that if that's really worth it
is it always hard work you know like you
know what we're doing you know you know
you don't want you for being honest no
for a hundred i understand what you're
saying you know what i mean we're being
honest but it's just you know when you
said that
having a lot of partners takes a toll on
you
that as well
so it's maybe not hard to work
but
it's kind of like when people said like
being a mom is the hardest job in the
world and then bill burr went crazy yeah
it's not the hardest job it's not the
hardest i'm not saying you know what i
mean like sometimes people say this
stuff to romanticize it you can respect
it without saying it's very difficult
work you a street walker okay i
understand if you're doing that stuff i
understand there's a toll and there's a
cost for it but let's not make it sound
like it's some more difficult job
you know what i'm saying there's a
reason why some people choose that life
hold on hold on hold on go ahead it's
taxing they put it that way that's a
better word we all pay very taxes we all
pay we all pay taxes sometimes square
money some other people that's with
everyone got the upsides and downsides
but i just don't like the idea that
making listen you cannot denigrate it
without saying it's like some
i don't know it's just work it's needed
if you want to say it it's work it's
what it's taxes it's work i like that
it's work it's work yes it's work okay
but it's taxing yes it's very taxing you
have to be honest they have to be able
to to to see what you're idolizing and
what you're you know the truth of it
anyways all this to say
just wanted you guys to be aware of this
stuff no one needs to be disillusioned
okay
i'm not mad at some women who do the
work and also admit to doing it i
respect that far more than the ones you
pretend yeah huh all my hard work got me
here no it didn't stop lying
stop lying didn't get you a private jet
i didn't want to
just say you're [ __ ] with the right
[ __ ] that's fine a lot of y'all start
camping so these are my thoughts i want
you guys to know the truth about this if
you guys want to go down the rabbit hole
tag the sponsor's a [ __ ] up website
but they expose a lot of people uh and
there's if you guys want me to do a
longer video i can tell you guys some of
the downsides and the bad things that
happen within that industry that are
crazy they want that if you want that we
could do that we could do that so you
guys leave a comment all right but yeah
also if you guys are liking today's
video make sure to like and comment okay
hit that subscribe button youtube's not
always kind to us so it helps
[Music]
foreign
i
[Music]